i was reading this week about parlor do
you know what parlor is oh yeah
do you know what parlor is one guy good
okay
he's in the military oh he's not it's uh
i mean you can be on it it's it's
it's like the turning into like the
right wing twitter
the right one facebook uh it was shot to
number one
on in the apple store and google okay
um if you think it's bad that we have
curated feeds now which we do of course
we don't all see the same news we see
the opposite news
that's why a vast majority of
republicans still think
trump won the election right right but
now we're going to have
different platforms apparently this is
because and i was criticizing someone
last week
for going up for they twitter threw off
this guy he was
one of the heads of homeland security
and he was giving his opinion about the
wall and mexicans and it wasn't my
opinion but it was an opinion
right it should not have been shut down
they're not doing it well
so now these people of course are saying
well we'll go start our own
and they did and now we're not ever
going to hear the same information
i don't know how we achieve these goals
that you're talking about
worthy though they are one of the things
we can achieve is let people have a
forum
but make sure you know who they are it's
like
you're a health guy right in the 1970s
my mother lobbied so hard to get
ingredients put on the boxes of the food
she was feeding her child
well the social media platforms need to
do that by putting a check next to every
single member
i had to be vetted to go on twitter and
facebook i'm sure you did i'm sure you
did right so people know
that it's really us well that needs to
be every single
member so i know i'm not listening
to sergey and igor in kaliningrad
right but if we if we want to bring back
people you know bring back the right we
have to at least
pretend slightly that every single major
news network is not completely leftist
right you know oh i was just trying to
watch the returns everyone was crying so
go to msnbc no they're crying too
if we're crying about the returns from
allegheny county
and we're just explicitly showing that
our newscasters
are so completely biased of course the
right's going to go somewhere else of
course they're going to leave
the traditional news and you know the
new york times forget it it has nothing
to say
to the right and i think that's where we
all that's this issue that
our country actually needs us you know
we all need to grow up but news
gathering sources need to grow up
the people on air no more crying on the
news like they'll
tell you about somebody getting beheaded
after school but then you get the
allegheny county returns
oh my god they just have to be taken out
in a stretcher
we you know we're just gonna have to
really suck it up
and be a little less partisan in the
news i agree
you